we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two David Pete and the
voicemail line is made possible this is
really great for us by our friends over
at Ling Vista which is an awesome
language learning app for Spanish French
German and Russian it learns your
current skill level in the language and
then it uses a I powered memorization
techniques to speed up your language
learning I've been refreshed my French
with it you can try it for free no
credit card needed at Ling viscom slash
Pakman Li ng VI st.com slash Pakman ok
let's get to today's voice mail
it is a follow up on my follow-up to the
I got a tax cut thanks to Trump video
from last Monday take a listen to this
hey David I just watched your video
about you getting a tax cut from Trump I
really recommend you look through the
comment section carefully because I
think there's a lot of confusion and a
lot of people including myself would
think you've got some things wrong so I
appreciate if you could check it out and
see if you could clarify any of that oh
man so yeah I did the segment last
Monday and I pointed out the reasons why
me getting a tax cut doesn't correlate
with an economic least immutable
stimulative tax plan and all sorts of
just factually wrong responses cropped
up in response to the video so on
yesterday's show I did a follow up kind
of picking six common themes that people
responded with and pointing out why each
of them is wrong and doesn't make any
sense and if you look at the comments on
the follow-up video they're identical
it's as if I wasn't spending time
correcting people's misunderstandings
about how taxes work from the first
video people just said the exact same
stuff so I'm done at this point sort of
correcting and following up and
addressing rebuttals to my tax cut video
because I did it once and people just
write to me with the exact same stuff
it's almost like they write in
without having listened to or watched
the entire video so count me out on that
one one response is all you're going to
get from me we've got a great bonus show
for you today
become a member become a patron to get
instant access to the bonus show
world-famous bonus show coming up next